we wanted to show you an overview
followed by that uh the next segment is
to tell you more about the structure of
the program
and how the sessions will be conducted
and to answer any questions that you
have for this training so i'll start
with my introduction so my name is mohit
and i have a phd in computational
biology and over 40 publications on
various uh topics uh research topics
research problems
that i was able to collaborate and work
with different scientific groups
and in in pine biotech we are helping
students to achieve some of those
outcomes through specific sort of
training which are very targeted and
today we are going to discuss this great
opportunity to learn about a very uh
innovative incoming and very important
field of
life science which is precision medicine
and uh it's
uh it's uh training that we have
designed that is uh that is something
that you will not be able to find
elsewhere so
about the sessions the way we have
scheduled this entire program includes a
lot of resources that you can learn and
take on your own so you will have your
uh your own time uh the at which you can
learn from these resources which we will
be sharing throughout the program uh
however we will also have uh uh live
sessions uh which are like 10 live
sessions which we have
scheduled for the month of june and july
where we will be discussing about these
steps several topics and you'll have an
opportunity to discuss and ask the
mentors while we go through these topics
and discuss uh several of these projects
and case studies that elia was
mentioning but before that like i think
the best place for me to show you this
is the learn page where we have put
together where we have put all of this
together uh so um if anyone can confirm
that um sonalika if you can confirm or
elia you can confirm if you can see my
browser as well
yeah we can see
all right perfect
so as i said
this is the first orientation session
where we wanted to tell you uh take you
through the
through the program and tell you that
why we are conducting this program what
are the benefits and what we are going
to go through this in in this entire
research based uh experience so it's
very important to understand that what
will be the flow when will be the
sessions uh
held and how much access you will have
for all of these resources so we have
put together this program page on
learnomicslogic and this is the link
for this page
that you will find in the chat
so in here we have described the
sessions with dates and the topics that
will be covered along with that very
interestingly you'll find the associated
resources hyperlinked in this page and
this is a great place to overview the
entire program because we will have the
first session on 14th of june uh which
will be the start of the program where
we will be discussing and taking you
through the specific specialized
sessions with expert but before that
like the time that you have we will
encourage you to take
the uh
take the program and start with some of
the preparatory materials that we'll be
sharing once you register so uh we will
talk about the registration uh towards
the end of this webinar we will where we
will be taking you through the
through the different subscription
levels that we have and the benefits
within those levels but before that
let's discuss the sessions one by one
and the resources that it associates uh
with it so the first session we are
going to start with a major problem the
cancer research problem and cancer
problem that ilia was describing in much
detail so without uh taking much of your
time i'll just try to tell you that we
are going to start with some of these
case studies where the a lot of ngs lot
of data science and lot of
other technologies are used so we have
these different examples for you to
learn from so we will be discussing
about the complexity of cancer and where
bioinformatics is used where this entire
big data is being generated how this
data is being generated and then how
what are the different ways we can
visualize this data understand what is
in there and where to look for so we
have uh also uh included some of these
project examples for you to get started
uh and understand and look at the
overview so if you click on some of
these links and open it in a new tab uh
so you'll find out that what kind of uh
material is associated with one of these
lessons so i already have a subscription
here so i've been able to go into each
of these courses and see that how a
detailed lesson is
is provided within these links now uh
after the first session where we'll be
introducing about the problem cancer
problem and
where the application is we will learn
about some of the emerging and important
technologies through which we can find
some of the interesting facts that elia
was describing
about finding specific mutations
understanding how to analyze genomic
data so the next session which was which
would be on 16th of july
sorry june we will be discussing about
the next generation sequencing uh method
call and application of genomics where
we will be learning about from the very
beginner level we have materials put
together on genomics so there is a
course three on omics logic that
describes the
the genomics from a dna uh point from a
beginner level where you're learning
about dna and structure to the big data
and like how to interpret how do you map
variants how do you detect and find
those small changes which is equivalent
to finding needle in a haystack so uh
the first session after the first
session and the second session which
would be on genomics we will be going
through a case study and this is a very
uh interesting case study on oncogene
variant calling and again you can always
uh take
go to this page and check for yourself
these links and go to these links and
understand that what this project would
be all about and what this session will
be about and what we will be covering so
here there's an example of a new project
on
oncogene variant calling that we'll be
covering in this in this uh case study
session where we will be discussing
about like you know understanding that
how mutations and variations uh
accumulate with time and are passed on
to the progeny and then how how do you
find this prominent mutation that could
help you find answers to some of the
major problems when we are looking at a
strategic
strategic plan to stop or design
clinical trials for these cancer
studies so uh understanding that would
be
understanding genomics and understanding
how genomics can be applied and how
genomics is applied in real research so
it's it's a part of a mixed logic
training that you have to go through
some of those data sets that we have put
together from high value publications
from uh from peer-reviewed
articles and also data sets that are
really um
are really digested well in the
community and have a
translational research outcome followed
by that we have a session on um
on 23rd which describes the
transcriptomics data analysis because
when we are talking about precision
medicine we are describing that how
different types of data helps in
understanding
the
how we can come up with a solution
strategy which is much
personalized and helps in finding those
answers
within small cohorts so here we are
looking at gene expression data we are
trying to understand that how do you
interpret and under and analyze gene
expression data using statistics using
uh machine learning unsupervised machine
learning so we will start understanding
about analyzing the transcriptomics data
using uh different uh uh algorithms and
workflows on t by info platform as well
as uh applying downstream analysis
processes to visualize to understand the
nature of the data and the patterns from
the data using machine learning methods
so from here on we will be learning
about different machine learning methods
that could be utilized in understanding
and visualizing and interpreting the
data that is generated from these
experiments where we have patient
samples where we have cell line data
where we have data from mouse models and
uh all of these data resources is
something that are playing huge huge
role in every day's research in like
cutting edge research so how do you find
these data sets is something that we are
going to cover in the next session which
would be an amazing session because uh
understanding how to analyze data and
then finding data kind of summarizes it
all that uh how one can go go about a
new research how one can
you know develop a research question so
these five sessions are going to cover
some of the major aspects including some
of these important data repositories
such as ncbi sra ncba geo and tcga
cosmic and all of those
that you might also be interested in
interested of and you can also uh be a
part of this these sessions by
registering for the program and ask and
add your own you know areas and discuss
with us and so that we can help you in
uh in understanding more uh the next
session is again a case study on
modeling cancer precision medicine
where we will be taking you through this
project uh you can obviously take take a
look at this link also so this project
tells about uh
breast cancer data again and finding
genomic mutations and understanding that
how um
how different types of responses to
treatments are integrated with
different types of omics data so this
will include machine learning as well as
uh use of omics data
and integrating uh the drug response so
that you understand that how this is
applied in uh precision medicine which
is very relevant to the program so after
this uh after the session we have a more
uh a session which is more focused
towards clinical diagnosis because we
are talking about precision medicine so
we are talking about different types of
challenges that
that the world is facing which includes
you know multi-drug resistance which
includes you know finding uh
stage specific uh
interventions uh and all of that so
we'll be learning about different case
studies here uh we will be learning
about you know how viruses on how
bacterias how pathogens are also uh
causing some of the major diseases which
we were not able to correlate before
without the analysis of big data but
with the help of big data and different
types of big data we've been able to
analyze and correlate and understand
that how this plays a role in clinical
diagnosis now um as as we were
discussing before and we went through
this entire uh overview by elia brodsky
where we learned about that not only
cancer but a lot of analysis and
especially after the koid outbreak has
been done for infectious disease
research where precision medicine is
playing a vital role so from cancer we
will move to another important aspect of
you know human health which is
infectious diseases here we will learn
about host response to viral infection
then we will learn about uh the kovid 19
case study that we have put together so
there is also a
project that we will be discussing in
this session and you can also check this
co a project 2 that we have on kovit
which is available on learn portal where
we will be discussing about
uh as we discussed also like how this
hap how this affects the host and also
what are the different
transcriptional signature when we have a
treatment so understanding from a drug
response level to understanding how the
at a genomic level this plays a role
when we are looking at the genome of the
virus itself
so i mean very exciting sessions that we
have put together so after july 14th we
have july 19th uh which is like the
final session where we are going to
discuss how all of this information
makes sense for you to work on your own
project uh different case studies
putting together a logic from you know
developing from introduction to
developing a research question and
finding a results and then you know
validating it and uh trying to uh work
on a research project so advancements in
precision medicines areas and
opportunities and uh also like this
includes the opportunities that are
there um with
uh with which we are sharing regularly
on our social media handles so um this
is what we have put together for uh you
to learn in this summer program which is
bioinformatics for precision medicine
and uh
i'll be happy to answer any of questions
so far if you have uh
about the schedule about the sessions
about the timing about the time
commitment that you would need to you
know go through all of this so um please
feel free to ask your questions in the
chat and i'll be happy to uh answer
those
next we will be taking you through the
registration process and telling you
what different subscription models that
we have that actually helps every every
individual participant to get this
personalized experience in for
learning uh precision medicine and
application of bioinformatics
environments